what up YouTube Facebook or wherever the
hell you're watching this video you're
about to watch a very interesting piece
of content in my opinion I'm trying to
be better I'm trying to give you more
value this is an incredibly insightful
piece of content that we recorded that
we don't normally show which is a
complete under the hood of us analyzing
our strategies coming up with new ones
this is a breakdown of how we're
thinking about going forward with our
content there's no greater thing no
greater gift I can give you than to show
you the strategy strategies where I win
this is the strategy the meetings the
kind of meetings that get us to the
places that deliver some of the best
business results in content today I care
about the content and a content
distribution strategy all that [ __ ] will
work itself out
if our messenger bot strategies right if
we get back to getting our BS you like
strategy right if we like actually have
a you know YouTube and and snapchat like
all that [ __ ] works out it's how we got
here in the first place you know like
it's very thank you so much it's very
easy to get just making sure no no I'm
just gonna thank you so much I know the
kitchens closing Zune or what have you
to me that's we don't have like we can't
be this far along and be less we're less
effective on YouTube and Instagram than
we were six months ago that's just not
smart give me give me your two cents on
the internet part why why are you saying
with us my point of view while we get
the jam on this is that the thought the
the of my ability over the last three
months not predicated on being busy to
post four times a day is completely
predicated on my personal subjective
point of view on what content will work
and because I'm so in my [ __ ] and I'm
not like Splenda my being right is so
high like
I'm even like trying to post a little
bit more and like literally watching
these posts get like 30,000 or this and
that like I can just feel it I can feel
it my soul I just want to post four
times a day and I want to get into a
better approving my quotes or you know
like we're just not getting stuff like
like I don't - the reasons why I'm mad
about it is so we did this thing heavy
hitters breaking the team into three
groups four or five people in each group
and everybody decides on the five posts
that they want to send you and
collectively everyone s basically agree
that they think that's the best version
of how we're gonna make the best content
it's great in parallel that I think us
like you doing that one for that there's
a lot of versions I would say 80% of
anything we do in that vein we have to
give you two cents on hey we want to do
this what's your take on it do you want
to do that like Taylor I want our
versions of those was that like the
fitness meme one
if there's a picture of you in 2013
that's really cool yeah probably not
that's what I'm sitting on it because I
think the thing that we have to use
those for team garyvee the thing that
I'm a hundred percent the thing that I
struggle with is that I don't like you
guys are you and I mean meaning it's I
get why you guys do it cuz it's not you
I wouldn't do it because it's too
self-serving like even the Fitness one
I'm like what am I doing here I'm
bragging that I got into shape like I'll
go I'll always go into that what I've
noticed a subtle thing for tonight is
like and it's not that you're doing
anything wrong it's because you're
Taylor and I'm Gary
but I'm posting as Gary for Gary and so
yeah I've seen that theme a lot that's
come through a lot of a lot of me even
when we were in our best zone the thing
that would be I actually just I've
learned the most is winter I'll just
take a step back so I know it I mean
we're making and then I was like wait
and I look at your profile and I'm like
oh
and I'm just getting a feel of what
you're actually posting versus not I
just don't like creating so much that
doesn't get posted yeah that just makes
no [ __ ] sense it's like you're
posting it on Team Gary B I'm thrilled
we have it that's a lot like if we have
by if there's five people on scene we're
saying these are the five things that we
can make I think if you don't post it
we're through it does that means team
Gary we should be awesome that's fine so
do it and in parallel I really like what
we're trying to get you it's only like
two or three days in of sending you five
quotes every morning let's move them
have to be from last three days the
other three should be classics whatever
classics are from people in the comments
I think I understand so that's generally
why we've only gotten to have you as you
bring me no it's great okay something
that I was thinking on I was gonna text
you guys but Friday look that the
light-skinned black gay girl you met
with like yes she's awesome when I was
talking with her after I was like damn
there's no reason she should have been a
de vivir for like two minutes telling
her story about like watch it started
starting a blog it's cool yeah so much
we can do I think Babb and I today
really did something smart this whole
notion of two questions
it's just right like it's it's where I'm
my best it's what this all started with
is a scary be like
we've done we've done that in the past
I'm thrilled
like I love Q&A like I'll do it in my
car like I'll I know myself like to your
point maybe it's been brought up here in
air but like I [ __ ] love Q&A it's
where I show my strength that there be
more of a tube or sitting on three
thousand four thousand people will be
something hit ups trying in the CRM and
I'm forward to them are gonna follow up
with papers everything about their a was
everything about XYZ they can be you
know like the sneaker should now get
like we should definitely do something
very smart with my website where the
sneakers at the top with like you know
it's really funny to like watch things
like stuff that I'm doing like my
podcast is in the 50s to 70s when it's
my default URL and Instagram it's a
hundred when it's not it's real like it
takes a lot to move up 30 40 spots like
like daily be was pumping when I would
change the URL and put a post and push
to that so I think you know this is why
I want to go back to like being
thoughtful about the mix of this team
here the content and the first part like
the technology first part a CRM data a
message bots or things that nature like
you know first in lines now like this
thing that we definitely know is like
really powerful a couple things well
that's why today was super important
because first of all I need to be jab
the jab right hook and we're right hook
right hook right like we have to there's
a Jacobian Hawaii that was a giveaway
like that is exciting to me yeah like
going
it's just it's just exciting to be like
yo here's 3000 pizzas you mean it's like
it's a frozen pizza thing and I'll ship
it it's like no that's why I'm saying
they have to be why these they go but
this is our chance to like do some like
run ads in Hawaii for like Commodores
really like there's like a tanning salon
that's giving away free
there's a gym that's gonna give away gym
memberships there's a lot of those will
stuff then there's also like a beer
koozie know for example here's what's
interesting about Twitter what Wendy's
does well like my ability to hack
culture is super good I'm too busy so I
need somebody to be trained in like not
the trending hashtag but like what's
going on right now today and everything
that's lightweight and so much is
political
like just crowds angles so interesting
crowd tango
it's nice it's I think really
interesting it's what Facebook is an app
that Facebook's live that sources
basically what's trending and poppin and
most popular on Twitter and Facebook
Instagram so for example like reading
search we can know what the most top
post on Instagram or in the last 24
hours
so are viable explained do we have it do
it we have it through Facebook we have
it I say you're an example of like these
are the top three Instagram posts like
you would comment on if you want it's
def that every day I would do that right
now yeah I'm like in general it's gonna
be like I did it the other I did it the
other day and it like really worked like
like Boyd lost his mind I went to J
Balvin Instagram I'm basically was
starting to try to follow more people by
the way real quick I'm think about
unfollowing everybody and following one
person a day like what the like
basically what the game did with me
today which is what I pitched them to do
for me you remember what a hack it would
be if I followed a new one person every
single day everybody would come every
day to see who it is it would be like a
thing
it's the ultimate cosine and it would
become like a thing like yeah so Goods
up in 12 we go something in title I
think we like the night am both on your
Twitter but I know all of it
yeah I'm looking with that I think that
at all right that's not enough yeah I
definitely feel like we didn't do like
I'll be honest with you I don't need
dailyvee to get any more views for the
rest of my life and it's a huge win I'm
documenting the other Sam we have 87
million views on a video sitting right
now the thing that I said hasn't
happened yet
like when target gets bought my facebook
I'm gonna have a video get three million
views because I'm gonna recall like to
me daily beats about the recall not
about the views today I think we
definitely get you created for Twitter -
it's like lady to me Twitter's about
community management telling you there's
so much to be done
surprising to like community management
hacking the current trends making jokes
about what's happening in real life
you know to me it's like has it been as
of right now with you
those to me you know what Twitter is
about Twitter's about somebody Seth
being on with avi being on his way down
to Philadelphia right now and giving
Meek Mill a thousand roses what I'm
that's what I'm really good at
like like like rookie NBA player drop 61
like booker last year dropped like a
thousand 70 points we look into him find
out his favorite video game is paper boy
we buy 70 paper boys on ebay and we send
them to and then film it so Taylor Swift
Thank You economy that's what I'm really
good at it and like it becomes like I'm
Santa Claus
yeah it comes natural to me I like doing
it so in a world of that and saying how
do we easyread to reform our team yeah
well that's what because I think God
there yeah but down so we're literally
doing like hashtag first line quote on
Twitter are people are tweeting the
stuff that they want to see you closer
make and they think is a good quote if
you actually so it's this negative press
and the same thing is happening on
YouTube comments to people on support
Instagram Instagram live with another
famous person is very good idea like
that is that's the real way to scale
Sophie and Justin you know I real
freaked when we do this on the plane
people freaked when I do this a brunch
like this what we're feeling right now
is the meta moment of it all this is the
best content we make how we make the
sausage is what they [ __ ] care about
they're like these debates and like all
of it
qa2 I really think the combination of
dailyvees and the askgaryvee show is the
right answer because if you think about
it if every vlog has four questions
asked during the day one
I'm easy right like I know myself I know
what I like I know what I don't like I
like Q&A
thus I won't be like [ __ ] you like when
you're like hey I do Ansari I'm like oh
like but like questions I just like to
answer in general I just know they're
good there's some crazy but like
thinking about me you know shoutouts I'm
just great like for the three that I ran
it now seems really homey it's either
the highest was success fall down was
probably for me yeah yeah dude honestly
I'm so frustrated that we're getting
stupid or not smarter
I don't know I'm say we're now about to
play for back yeah that's it
yeah but out of out of like a random
over when I remembered I'm like yo can
we retaught about this again [ __ ]
Mazel Tov no I know that's why I don't
think so because I do think I think both
matter yeah it's just having the right
allocation well the robot is like cool
we have our budget where we valuation I
couldn't agree more
the good news is by doing all that we
have context instead of guessing so for
example Friday like I got a good one so
if I'm going to Philly and I'm not doing
the dinner now cuz it's not working why
didn't I do a secret meetup scavenger
hunt and just like [ __ ] just [ __ ]
hang out for an hour of the hundred
people
what do mean we can do stuff you mean
yeah I mean like just from an IG bio
alone we've alerted we have to find an
internet company we have to give a $25
gift card to everybody on their birthday
from like some sort of like gifts calm
like we have to find somebody who's like
into that just nice like I agree
people like 50 bucks even more I want it
honestly we need to and we need to
really give some thought I think maybe
Justin we should train him we'll take
him awhile I have to do what I used to
do Oh God
when somebody was like when I was like
when I then like vomit at the build org
told a story from nine years ago
you were there with me like literally I
tweeted once it's I know I have to learn
how to say no and some guy tweets at me
he goes I'll teach you sent me a hundred
bucks and I sent him a hundred bucks and
then 250 s and then he came to South by
and found me and wanted to give it back
but then I only took fifty of it back
like what something there's something
that I feel like we should be doing for
That Bird Areas do we do it now no tweet
what fun thing can I do for you love
that [ __ ]
you won't like give them wine or beer to
user remember I sent a dude a burger and
Wyoming like that's a chef this is that
ever going to do yeah what can I do for
you today
and then what I call this dude's NB
a--'s first day working with you what -
I think India's first day we're going
through Chevy a clunky feels like an
iced coffees yeah
[Music]
I want to do something so crazy at the
NFL Draft
we're gonna try every up yeah
when they kept that wait here to live
waiter the big thing is we're filming
everyday and we're we're not playing it
right I really sense it even like fabin
when you're like can you do this and I'm
like and IO was like I was like really
going to pay you know especially right
now you're so deep in vaynermedia late
imma are looking at the schedule and I'm
like I know nothing is gonna happen
today I just need you to be more useful
our time on those days I'm cool with
that
I'm cool with that I feel like I've
gotten there the vlog we nailed the vlog
we do keynotes we like nailed it it's
like the Gary Vee audio experience I
want a document as much as possible it's
cool I was in Boston today look I do
think the QA changes everything like
I'll tell you this
I like QA and like one out of every two
times I think as I'm walking in between
one meeting to the four DS I'll answer
if one [ __ ] question it's I like it
there's something I like it different
than like make a snapchat video and be
like what I like I like it hundred
thousand that's right that's right by
the way we don't need them to come in
have every single one of these
influencers on the 5000 B list send in a
video question I'll answer it that's the
two-minute video and target their fans
you want a good idea like you know where
we're not even close the Hasan Minhaj
and me clip of the Houston Rockets and
Cavs fan clipped properly right now
while Houston and the Cavs are in the
playoffs it's just not smart it's like
so good
you know it's interesting to know a lot
of our [ __ ] well we just can't help it
there's so much molecules and this is
why I like that kid Dustin I don't think
that's in the vein of d-roc or baton
really in terms of their skill size and
how they see content in the content they
want to be they want to be swaggy and
artist and all that [ __ ] I think the
person that would crushed that 660
second version of the sama knowledge is
someone who does like epic viral fails
good you know what I mean pom-pom
thriller what do you get that I mean I
think you guys should definitely do it
but you're not like it's not default no
it's not whereas somebody else who's a
15 year old kid now that was their early
craft it's not what you were influenced
by and Twitter's interesting what are
you suggesting for me because it's
native them in it all the time I reply
to more people tweeting about the text
about happy birthday than I ever doing
anything in the text you know especially
culture right now cultures by the way it
always has
even when Twitter was in its Lowell
there is no social network
there's no place Twitter's the water
cooler but Twitter is the place where I
can do so much because like for example
Twitter is the place where I can like
people people I'm always taking the high
road anytime I even show any level of
rebuttal people go crazy like like like
crazy
they're like so happy that I finally get
them bless you like there's like
throwing shade at stuff or like and
especially as my profile is getting
bigger now like I I was never in a place
where I was actually like like I can
definitely now engage with a celebrity
and have something happen
[Music]
again any celebrity on Twitter says I'm
hungry like sending them a burger is
better we will kill that [ __ ] you do the
process assume who's get you become a
character sure of yourself it's forever
you know
that's why I like the Q&A and the LAV
brings real value it brings two things
I'm good at it so why like a dailyvee
needs to just literally be like like
here's what we need to think here's
where you guys can get a little more
creative so let's talk about this so I I
literally go like two for 31 from that
field like I played terrible the other
day right I wonder if that dailyvee
needs to actually be show every one of
my shots that I missed and then how do
we manifest which is not easy how do we
manifest me talking about like you like
like the fact that like businesses like
that to like you can lose you can
literally like miss 31 shots but if you
make one like why do I keep shooting
yeah I mean that's like a classic saying
that's not mine but like just the notion
of like the mindset of like they're my
miles like cool you can protect my tooth
Oh
[Music]
we should do way more engagement and
whiteboard stuff like I need to film
something tomorrow where my hand goes
even lower like like we need like that
post but that was unbelievable you know
was great about that post I am in it
like not that it was luck I'm so
grateful that I went with the like
tagging thing like it was really it was
the right post to do that call aback
that created absurdity that's what made
it like it worked together like the
vision like the visual is amazing
it's like it great thank you the visual
is [ __ ] crazy like it looks like I'm
coming out of an Instagram post it's
really cool you know be really cool
could I do it somewhere like I'm trying
to like like could I make them can I do
this and basically it seems like I'm
talking to wait a minute how is it set
up yeah can I basically reference the
next photo in your stream that'd be
really cool it like everyone has like a
different experience yeah a little bit
like when you do choose to self-censor
so
but like look look at it right here I am
like how do you do like so virtually
melted bottoms because we're keeping the
bottom I mean can you pick the top it's
not gonna look it's cool I think we
should do what you're saying I could
what about archiving like that would
archive nobody gives a [ __ ] right but I
mean this one does right we're doing the
blue arrow but like maybe if I like
really time it and I'm coming out in two
but again we faked it right so it's not
doing something about I love what you do
like to call somebody misspoke doing the
air like tech like out someone you have
following today like even doing like a
handwritten message to you and it's just
like a general like hey I love you
haven't talked to you in a while and
then we did you pointing like the share
button maybe it's like share this is the
first thing you know you need to share
the problem to share about neuron right
now and every phone is different on the
sizing of the photo all right yeah your
photo like when you point it and care
about button on your photo then we
different that live for me we should do
if any of you actually tapping the
buttons like basically that's still more
of that video informative tax part
highlights where you tap the share yeah
it was do you guys see this
I apologize to do you see this oh yeah
it's got seventy eight thousand likes
just yeah I do you think for you
photos of me have work about ryujin and
you know what really works I got it but
you know what really works is good
photos yeah the same thing that
everybody actually does in Instagram
which is like really cool we should do
that man this whole notion of motivation
and optimism is a strategy not like some
vanilla I'm tapping into something I
haven't fully like yeah
now watch another thing I'm on to
something with it I haven't figured it
fully fully out but it's a hundred
percent right
yeah call next week we're working on
that photo slideshow yeah dude how's it
going it's better Sid was playing with
it more from like let me talk to you
about it as a deck and like now it needs
to be an article as a deck that's some
creepers press button it all makes sense
but it should be done buddy call I made
an article off of it because you
basically open up that Dutch Postino
with like it's the greatest here to live
give me alive it's not even a question
and I just don't understand how you
could look at it any other way and by
the way it also helps you to be looking
and things like this it's unbelievable
how many people bring it up it's just so
big
you're pushing about three times a week
on salaries to first snapchat mister
there is times that our over-indexing
like like Sunday nights super
interesting I think if we looked at our
Sunday night data Sunday nights super
interesting yeah if you think about it
if you think about something that
historically it's like the HBO shows
like it's Sunday night it's like a it's
a it's a unique moment it's a unique
moment of source of the general thing is
that the taxi didn't always I get it
but I met that if there's the top of the
sphere of whatever you are I'll tell you
right now though the way the Instagram
algorithm on comment is right now I
should be commenting on top people left
and right it's such a hack I'm gonna go
to meek Mill's Instagram right now and
win
[Music]